avant de de vous laisser le garde vous
dit Mister Francis situé de t'évader en
tabac comme les autres
Francis collant bonsoir
alors
Francis colon
en décembre 2012 alors que vous
travaillez pour un groupe français au
Nigéria vous êtes kidnappé par les
djihadistes d'anne-saru des dissidents
de Boko Haram après plusieurs mois d'une
préparation millimétrée vous réussirez à
vous évader tout seul alors Francis
c'est incroyable histoire vous leur
racontez dans un livre intitulé
l'évasion chez XO édition et à 20h dans
Salut les Terriens
[Musique]
Francis Colomb bonsoir
en décembre 2012 j'avais été kidnappé
par ansaru des dissidents de Boko Haram
au vu des revendications vos chances de
survie étaient nulles mais pendant 11
mois vous allez organiser votre évasion
au millimètre et finalement la réussir
on va raconter votre histoire vous êtes
né le 19 décembre 1949 à
Saint-Julien-du-Verdon dans les Alpes de
Haute-Provence votre père dirige une
centrale électrique de l'EDF et votre
mère est institutrice
vous avez 14 ans quand votre mère meurt
c'est le début des embrouilles mauvaises
rencontres petit larcin c'est comme ça
qu'un jour avec votre deux chevaux vous
emmener trois types à Toulon vous
ignoriez complètement qui préparait un
coup
à 20 ans vous retrouvez en tôle quand
même bah oui mais six mois
mais c'est pas mal parce que cette
fréquentation des mecs du milieu des
méchants des mafieux vous endurci et
vous servira finalement 40 ans plus tard
exactement alors après la prison et un
court séjour dans l'armée de l'air à 25
ans vous choisissez la vie d'expat en
Afrique vous allez travailler dans 26
pays différents faites quoi exactement
je suis ingénieur en électromécanique
alors en décembre 2012 vous dirigez un
chantier à Rémy qui est une ville de 200
000 habitants dans le nord du Nigéria
votre position à ce moment là et
d'installer des éoliennes
anticycloniques c'est-à-dire des
éoliennes sont rabattables en fait en
cas de tempête c'est ça exactement alors
à cause de Boko Haram vous êtes logés
dans une maison sécurisée par quatre
policiers nigérian qui sont équipés de
gilets pare-balles de kalachnikov oui
vous savez que c'est dangereux oui mais
bon quand vous avez vécu parce que
j'étais depuis 2011 vous avez pas
forcément la peur parce que les gens les
Africains sont déjà merveilleux le 19
décembre 2012 si votre anniversaire
vous allez chercher une amie qui
s'appelle Esther pour qu'elle vienne
avec vous passer votre anniversaire vous
rentrez
à peine arrivé dans le salon vous
entendez des rafales de kalachnikov et
là vous avez la bonne idée de cacher
Esther derrière un canapé
voilà soudain une explosion la porte en
acier vol en éclat les terroristes entre
dans votre maison et vous arrivez à les
détourner du canapé c'est carrément ils
vont vers le canapé la sortie c'est par
là j'ai pas voulu qu'il peut repasse
parce qu'il aurait tué comme ils ont tué
les deux policiers donc je suis passé
par les SAS alors je le dis Esther sera
sauvé
grâce à vous elle est toujours en vie
oui
je suis fier dans le jardin c'est le
carnage deux militaires sont morts et un
gosse de 15 ans qui venait recharger son
portable dans une prise du jardin le
pauvre a été tué aussi
dehors donc il y a trois quatre quatre
dix types masqués par un kéfié ils sont
armés de kalachnikov et de
lance-roquette et là on vous enfile un
sac en plastique sur la tête ce qui est
très compliqué pour vous parce que vous
êtes asthmatique oui et j'ai eu tout de
suite du mal à respirer oui puis vous
avez eu quand même un triple pontage il
y a quelques années et puis après ils
m'ont quand même mis aussi dans le
coffre de la voiture alors après 8
heures de route il y a un type qui est
défoncé défoncé aux quatre c'est une
herbe que les gens marchent puis ça fait
ça fait des boules dans la bouche c'est
le sucre
et puis il supportait pas la voiture
puisqu'il m'a vomi dessus et tout
alors ce type vous explique que les
Français doivent quitter l'Afghanistan
doivent quitter le Mali et qui doivent
abroger la loi anti voile intégral ce
qui est terrible c'est que les
revendications sont absolument
inacceptables pour la France donc vous
ça arrange pas vos affaires non pas du
tout parce que ils auraient demandé une
rançon ouais j'aurais pu croire que mais
là c'est que des romans politiques et
adressée au Président de la République
d'ailleurs alors là on finit par vous
jeter dans une cellule de 4 mètres par 3
seul en terre battue matelas pourri et
avant de vous laisser le garde vous dit
Mister Francis situé de t'évader en
tabac comme les autres ah oui et surtout
qui venait d'abattre 7 qu'ils avaient
pris sur un chantier en italien en
anglais et tout ça donc c'est
ça ça vous prend alors là évidemment
vous vous retrouvez c'est la solitude
oui dans mon malheur j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir une petite radio que je leur ai
pleuré qui m'ont accordé trois semaines
après je crois ou j'entends des RFI
et puis j'entendais des gens merveilleux
quoi qui font chaud au cœur vous finirez
par entendre votre femme d'ailleurs qui
a la Réunion alors là vous décidez de
prendre sur vous de ne pas vous laisser
aller
[Musique]
des médicaments que je pouvais connaître
tout ce qui était chinois ou que je
prenais pas là vous êtes extraordinaire
quand même Francis c'est que vous
commencez à vous entraîner en vue de cet
évasion évidemment il faut marcher et
quand on est en cellule c'est compliqué
donc vous mettez le matelas au milieu de
la cellule et vous faites le tour du
matelas vous faites 1000 tours de
matelas par jour ce qui fait 10 km ça
vous garde en forme évidemment oui je
faisais du fractionné aussi parce que de
temps
ce qu'on apprend au rugby j'ai fait du
rugby dans ma jeunesse aussi j'ai pas
fait que des bêtises
alors là vous commencez à organiser
votre évasion le portail vous pouvez pas
passer dessus parce qu'il est trop haut
pour être escaladé et vous pouvez pas
ouvrir parce que les gonds sont rouillés
et là ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
comme il vous donne plus de riz avec des
pâtes il vous donne des beignets des
beignets de maïs qui sont cuits dans
l'huile de palme et là vous récupérez
l'huile de PA des beignets de maïs dans
un bouchon d'une bouteille de Coca-Cola
pour mettre sur les gonds du portail
c'est génial ben c'est mon côté génial
c'est un travail de fourmis oui j'ai
besoin d'une poignée ou fabriquer une
poignée avec une brosse à dents vous
taillez exactement vous préparez bien
votre truc et puis alors l'avantage
évidemment c'est que tous ces gens là
prient cinq fois par jour donc ça vous
laisse le temps de tester vos bricolages
alors pour tuer le temps donc vous
discutez aussi avec votre geôlier et là
vous découvrez quand même le niveau du
mec il sait pas que la terre est ronde
quoi non c'est fou ça quand même c'est
alors il y a un truc aussi qui est
marrant c'est que le mec il a des
érections absolument incroyables il
prend 3 viagra par jour
[Rires]
des filles pour oui oui il avait une
femme et il voulait en reprendre une
autre voilà quoi alors le 25 septembre
après 8 mois de travail acharné la
rouille sur le portail finit par céder
ça c'est le moment extrêmement important
évidemment c'est la grande évasion ce
truc là c'est alors il est temps de
mettre les voiles mais le jour du départ
le jour vous allez décider de partir
c'est le drame on vous transfère c'est
horrible vous avez récolté cette huile
de palme dans la capsule de Coca-Cola
pendant des mois et là au moment de
partir on vous transfère tout est à
refaire
vous vous retrouvez dans une nouvelle
maison dans une grande ville alors là le
problème c'est qu'il y a des barreaux
fenêtres et le gardien d'or dans la
chambre à côté
alors là vous vous mettez à attendre
qu'il oublie ses clés sur la porte comme
dingue oui parce qu'il avait pas de
douche tant qu'il venait voilà il
passait par ma chambre j'étais un
captivité et j'avais une porte qui
donnait sur voilà une douche enfin c'est
une douche africaine c'est le seau d'eau
le 12 novembre il oublie ses clés voilà
vous en profitez pour inspecter la
maison en espérant qu'ils les oubliera à
nouveau il faut quand même avoir le
moral pour se dire ce mec a oublié ses
clés je pourrais m'enfuir mais non je
suis pas prêt j'attends qu'il les oublie
à nouveau problème c'est qu'il les a
oublié dans la un jour et moi je voulais
pas qu'il fasse ce jour ce que vous
voulez c'est qu'ils oublient à 18h voilà
et là le 16 novembre à 18h le gardien
oublie les clés bonne nouvelle vous
partez et bientôt vous marchez dans la
rue mais vous marchez calmement parce
que vous dites si je me mets à courir ça
va se voir donc il faut avoir le moral
quand même vous marchez dans la rue
voilà sans courir vous apprendrez après
qu'il y a 50 djihadistes qui sont après
vous et à un moment vous tombez sur un
moto taxi qui vous emmène à la police
voilà Fabius viens vous chercher en
Falcon évidemment
vous avez perdu 40 kg mais vous êtes en
bonne santé là oui ça va j'ai repris
heure
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu